[Music]
chipangu
is an island towards the east in the
high seas
1 500 miles distant from the continent
and a very great island it is
[Music]
the people are white civilized and well
favored
they are idolaters and are dependent on
nobody
and i can tell you the quantity of gold
they have is
endless for they find it in their own
islands
and the king does not allow it to be
exported moreover
few merchants visit the country because
it is so far from the main land
and thus it comes to pass that their
gold is abundant
beyond all measure i will tell you a
wonderful thing about the palace of the
lord of that
island you must know that he hath a
great
palace which is entirely roofed with
fine
gold just as our churches are roofed
with lead
in so much that it would scarcely be
possible to estimate its value
moreover all the pavements of the palace
and the floors of its chambers are
entirely
of gold in plates like slabs of stone
a good two fingers thick and the windows
also are of gold
so that altogether the richness of this
palace is past
all bounds and belief
they have also pearls in abundance which
are of a rose color
but fine big and round and quite as
valuable as the white ones
in this island some of the dead are
buried and others are
burnt when a body is burnt they put one
of these pearls in the mouth
for such is their custom they have also
quantities of other precious stones
kublai the grand khan who now reigns
having heard much of the immense wealth
that was in this island
formed a plan to get possession of it
for this purpose he sent
two of his barons with a great navy and
a great force of horse
and foot these barons were able and
valiant men
one of them called abba khan and the
other von seinchin
and they weighed with all their company
from the ports of zaton and
kinsei and put out to sea they sailed
until they reached the island of four
said and there they landed and occupied
the open country in the villages
but did not succeed in getting
possession of any city or castle
[Music]
and so a disaster befell them
as i shall now relate you must know that
there was much ill will between these
two barons
so that one would do nothing to help the
other and it came to pass that there
arose a north
wind which blew with great fury and
caused great damage along the coasts of
that island
for its harbours were few it blew so
hard
that the great khan's fleet could not
stand against it
and when the chiefs saw that they came
to the conclusion that if the ships
remained where they were
the whole navy would perish
so they all got on board and made sale
to leave the country
but when they had gone about four miles
they came to a small island
on which they were driven ashore in
spite of all they could do
and a large part of the fleet was
wrecked and a great multitude of the
force
perished so that there escaped only some
thirty thousand men who took refuge on
this
island these held themselves for dead
men
for they were without food and knew not
what to do
they were in great despair when they saw
that such of the ships as had escaped
the storm were making full
sail for their own country without the
slightest
sign of turning back to help them and
this
was because of the bitter hatred between
the two barons in command of the force
for the baron who escaped never showed
the slightest desire to return to his
colleague
who was left upon the island in the way
you have heard
though he might easily have done so
after the storm ceased
and it endured not long he did
nothing of the kind however but made
straight for home
and you must know that the island to
which the soldiers had escaped was
uninhabited
there was not a creature upon it but
themselves
now i will tell you what befell those
who escaped on the fleet
and also those who were left upon the
island
you see those who were left upon the
island some thirty thousand souls as i
have said
did hold themselves for dead men for
they saw no possible means of escape
and when the king of the great island
got news that one part of the expedition
had saved themselves on that island
and the other part was scattered and
fled he was
right glad and he gathered together all
the ships of his territory
and proceeded with them the sea now
being calm
to the little isle and landed his troops
all around it
and when the tartars saw them thus
arrive and the whole force
landed without any guard having been
left on board the ships
the act of men very little acquainted
with such work
they had the wisdom to feign flight now
the island was very high in the middle
and whilst the enemy were hastening
after them by one road
they fetched a compass by another and in
this way
managed to reach the enemy's ships and
get aboard of them
this they did easily enough for they
encountered no opposition
once they were on board they got
underway immediately for the great
island and landed there carrying with
them the standards and banners of the
king of the island
and in this way they advanced to the
capital
the garrison of the city suspecting
nothing wrong when they saw their own
banners advancing
supposed that it was their own host
returning and so gave them admittance
the tartars as soon as they had got in
seized all the bulwarks
and drove out all who were in the place
except the pretty women
and these they kept for themselves in
this way the great khan's people
got possession of the city
[Music]
when the king of the great island and
his army perceived that both fleet and
city were lost
they were greatly cast down however
they got away to the great island on
board some of the ships which had not
been carried off
and the king then gathered all his hosts
to the siege of the city
and invested it so straightly that no
one could go in or come out
those who were within held their place
for seven months
and strove by all means to send word to
the great khan
but it was all in vain they could never
get the intelligence carried to him
so when they saw they could hold out no
longer they gave themselves up
on condition that their lives should be
spared but still
that they should never leave the island
and this befell in the year of our lord
1279
the great khan ordered the baron who had
fled so disgracefully
to lose his head and afterwards he
caused the other also who had been left
on the island
to be put to death for he had never
behaved as a good
soldier ought to do
oh but i must tell you a wonderful thing
that i had forgotten which happened on
this expedition
you see at the beginning of the affair
when the khan's people had landed on the
great island and occupied the open
country as i told you
they stormed a tower belonging to some
of the islanders
who refused to surrender and they cut
off the heads of all the garrison
except eight on these eight they found
it impossible to inflict
any wound now this was by virtue of
certain
stones which they had in their arms
inserted between the skin and the flesh
with such skill as to not show at all
externally
and the charm and virtue of these stones
was such that those who wore them
could never perish by steel so
when the barons learnt this they ordered
the men to be beaten to death
with clubs and after their death the
stones were extracted from the bodies of
all
and were greatly prized now the story of
the discomfort
of the great khan's folk came to pass as
i have
told you but let us done with that
[Music]
matter